hi welcome to this amazing video on ICC
World Cup winner prediction 2023 so this
prediction will be based on the data we
have collected from sources like gagal
so if you love watching these type of
videos subscribe to our YouTube channel
and press that Bell icon to never miss
any update from Simply learn so without
any further Ado let's get started so
this is our jupyter notebook so you can
use any ID so here I will change first
name to
ICC word c
prediction okay yeah so first we will
import some necessary libraries for data
analysis and visualization so here I
will
import pandas
SD then I will import
numpy
as numi as
NP then I will
import M plot lip
do
pyplot as
PLT P
plot as
BL okay and the last one is import
c as
SNS so these are some major libraries we
will use throughout so pandas is a
python library that provides fast and
powerful flexible and easy to use data
analysis and manipulation tools this
pandas numai numai is a library for the
Python programming languages like adding
support for large multi-dimensional
array and matrices along with large
collection of high level mathematical
functions to operate on the arrays okay
so M plot lip M plot lip is a plotting
library for the Python programming
language and its numerical
mathematics extension num and it
provides an object oriented API for
embedding plots into application using
uh general purpose GUI toolkit like kter
wxpython or
gtk and the cbon cbon is a library for
making statical Graphics in Python it
builds on top of P plot lip and
integrates closely with Panda's data
seure okay so cbon helps you to explore
and understand your
data moving forward
uh we will uh import data set and you
guys can download these data set from
the description box
below so here I will
write World
Cup to pd. read uncore
CSV then World
Cup
CSV then I will import one more file
results equals to ad.
read
underscore
CSV then
results do
CSV okay so I will read these the data
frame uh results. CSV into the results
data frame
right let's run it okay
fine so let me display uh the World Cup
frame this first F so here I will write
World
Cup okay so this is uh file looks like
okay these are the you know team and the
titles or win percentage in Odis welcome
matches welcome matches
B so this is all the
data
so here uh I will make one small chart
number of titles wor by E team okay so
let me write here number of
titles one by each team right so here I
will write SNS do
set then RC equals
to figure
do figure
size okay and 20 ISO
5 okay so now I will create a barplot
using SNS do barplot to visualized Team
titles right so here I will write SNS do
barplot xals
to team
name then then y =
to
titles then
data equals to from
World
okay so now I will display the plot so
PLT do
show
okay
sorry comma
5 okay so as soon as team name typ does
data go World
Cup could not interpret into the team
name
okay team
titles why it's happening because T here
is capital okay T here is capital titles
okay so we need these two columns okay
so this is Australia India New
Zealand
right uh moving forward let's see win
percentage in ODI by E team okay so here
I will
write win
percentage in ODI by
eting right so same SNS do
set
rc+
figure do figure
size same 20 comma
5 right so again I will create the
barplot SNS dot
barplot x equals
to team
name comma y equals
to when
percentage
ODI comma data equals
to World
Cup okay here I will write pl.
show
okay again figure do fig RC paramet
RC
okay size spelling is
wrong my bad yeah so as you can see this
is a win percentage in ODI uh for the
respective
teams
right so this is all about about the
data we have okay we are getting these
uh statistics from the data only
right so here I will do number of
matches one
in World Cup by each
team right so I will copy from
here
and because every mostly the part is
same so I will again copy
full and I will change
[Music]
here to World
Cup
match
one right so this is World Cup match one
from the respective
team so here I have already wrote number
of matches won in World Cup by E team
right so here again Australia is
leading so let's check some recent ODI
ranking
so
recent
ODI
ranking right again we
need I will copy because why do write
again and again
so here I will change
into
rating again I reading a one Pakistan
second New Zealand England South afria
it is all about based on the data
right so moving forward so let me
display the first few rows of the uh
result data frame so here I will write
results
results do
head head if you use head you will
display it will display the top five
rows and if you use tail it will display
the last five rows from the data frame
okay so this is the
result uh data frame so here you can see
the first Was Bangladesh team to was
Pakistan and winner Was Bangladesh Bor
by 779 R and ground is this this this
right and the date is this
okay so removing uh let's remove the
rows with match abundant and no result
from the results data frame because of
no use so here I will write
results do drop from
results because anyways the draw
matches will not get any uh you know
analytics it won't help in
analytics if you want to become an AI
expert and gain handsome salary packages
look at wide range of AIML courses by
simply learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
program you will gain expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT explainable AI
machine learning algorithm supervis and
unsupervised learning model training and
optimization and there is much more on
the list with handson experience in
tools like chat JT Dal ithon open CV and
tens oflow you will catch the eye of top
recruiter so what are you waiting for so
hurry up androll now a year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses find the coursing in the
description box
below C
to
match
abundant
okay dot
index okay forgot
open here I will write
okay
results match
abandon let
on I will write in place equals
to
True
right okay I will copy this and paste
again here for the no
result here I will
write
no
result fine
yeah so let's have a setat of top five
teams in ODI World Cup 2023 okay so I
will write here
stats stats
of top five teams in the
ODI World Cup
2023 so let let's start with the Indian
team okay India
team let me make this like
this
yeah so here I will
write DF data frame equals
to uh
results
of team one
one
rights
to and we will check this for the top
five teams
India
results
of team
to cons to
India
right so let's create a new data frame
India containing all rows from the
filter data frame right
India equals to DF do
iock okay let me display India doad top
five
rows so this is team uh okay Bangladesh
India V Bangladesh B by this is
right and here I will filter the India
data frame to create a new data frame of
like India win containing rows where the
winner column is India okay so here I
will
write
India Vin to
India
winner
India right so here I will check India
let's
go okay so what I did here I you know
filtered the Indian data frame to create
a new data frame like where the India
only India wins so here you can check
this Bangladesh India India won by 77
run this this this all the matches won
by India right van
Stadium okay
so so this data is like till 2023 you
can see it is the latest
data right so moving forward we'll check
the number of wins in odis's against
other team because it it is like ODI
World Cup so that is why so I will write
here number
of wins
in
Odis
against other
teams so here I will exclude the team
India's
name okay
exclude
de value
to India
so now I will filter out the rows with
the excluded value so here I will write
filtered _ dfal
to India
when Indore wi
then team
two
it's not equals to flued
Value
right then let's count the occurrence of
each value uh in the data frame filter
data frame of T2 column Team 2 column so
value _ counts equals
to
filter underscore
DF team
to do
value
counts right and let's print the
values so West indes 6 New Zealand 4
Australia 3 so these are the number of
wins in Odis against other team right
so moving forward uh let's exclude Team
India
name
okay so it will be the same so let me
copy
here so the it was for the team two
right let me check for the team
one so here you can see Zimbabwe South
Africa
right as a team one so now let me
display the team India's wins against
other team using bar graph okay it will
look
good
goest I can copy from
here
okay then I will create the bar plot bar
chart the PLT do figure
figure
size to 8 comma
5 PLT do
bar
list
filtered
data Team
2 Dot value
counts then 0 ra
5 dot
keys right comma
list of
filtered data so I'm doing for one team
so later on we'll just copy paste and
change the team names okay because we
have to do for the top five teams and
filter
data
team
two
dot
value
underscore underscore
counts zero ratio
5 and then uh comma
color will
be blue
bold
right so uh all set and PLT do
show
right okay invalid some
let me check the
error
okay okay PLT bar is filter data filter
data is not
defined filter data
okay maybe spelling mistake
so as you can see I run this and there
was a spelling mistake so here you can
see the bar plot okay so moving
forward what we will
do we'll make the same for the team one
right it was for the team two so I will
copy from here paste it here so here I
will write team
one again have team
one again team
right yeah so this is for so basically
this uh is the bar I created for this
statis right for this data we
got so let's see the win percentage of
India against each
team okay so here I will write whenn
percentage
AG of India
against each
team
right
so I will write this code and come back
to
you so here I have already wrote the
team in counts Okay so out of the 1,32
ODI matches played by India number of
matches won against the following team
particular
team right and we already
excluded uh the Abundant matches or Draw
matches or no result matches right so
this is the total matches played is
calculated here and here we are India we
are getting like India's win percentage
against each team is calculated by this
particular line
of code so we are creating this time the
piie
chart right PLT dop you can see and here
what I'm doing is like I'm setting the
equal expect ratio show that the pie
chart is drawn as a circle right this is
a title okay let me run it so as you can
see Australia and the some of
Afghanistan or Netherland I guess huh
England Bangladesh Sri Lanka
Pakistan this is the win percentage
okay larger is from with the Sri Lanka
23.9
right so now let this is for the whole
ODI win percentage of India against East
team like total matches played from by
India now let's check the win percentage
of India in the ODI World Cup okay for
that I have
to write the same line of code so what I
will do I will copy paste and get back
to you so this is the win percentage of
India uh for the OD in the OD World Cup
okay this is the whole ODI matches and
this is the only for the World Cup India
played ODI matches right so now I will
create the same charts for the Australia
team Pakistan team England team the are
top five teams okay and I what I will do
I just copy paste the code for the
respective teams and just change the
name right and the stats okay so I will
do and I will get back to
you so as you can see here so let me run
it first so this is win percentage of
England in the odia team so I have
created these charts uh for the whole
five top five teams India Australia
Pakistan New Zealand and England based
on the data right I've have create I
gave so this is the stats for the
Australia team okay I gave the coloring
okay as per their Jersey color okay so I
gave Australia to yellow and see this is
the stats for the Pakistan teams the
same stats which I done it for the India
team right I gave them the green
color and this is the stats from the for
the New Zealand team black color and the
final is for the England team I don't
know why I gave the red color but it's
fine right so moving forward now we will
do some Eda explor data analysis and
let's see okay so I will create the list
of cricket teams participating in the
World Cup now so
World World Cup
teams okay
England
comma
South
Africa come
on okay let me give some
space West
indes
Goan then New
Zealand Sri
Lanka Afghanistan
from
Australia
Bangladesh and
India
right so let me filter the matches
involving only teams in the World Cup
team list okay so I will write DF _
teams oneals to results
then
results team
one dot is
in World Cup
teams right so here I extracted the
matches with a team one in the World Cup
right I will do it for the same for the
team two
right so moving forward what I will
do I will combine the filtered data
frames team1 and team two so I will
write DF uncore just teams now to PD do
conat DF uncore
teams one and DF
underscore teams
2 right so here I will concatenated the
two data frames
vertically uh so I will WR
dfdore teams. drop
duplicates
duplicates okay so I have removes the
duplicate uh rows if
any and here DF do
teams dot count right so uh let me count
the number of rows in the final data
frame
okay okay uh data frame object
no
DF
okay so it's not DF
doore right yeah so this is team one
team two winner okay margin ground right
so these are the number of rows right
date the 725 rows all the values are
same it's good to go so here let's
display the first few rowes of the DF
teams which we
created just right now
head right
okay
and let's uh remove unnecessary columns
from the DF teams I'm displaying the
first five view rows uh we are removing
unnecessary columns like date uh margin
ground we don't need this margin ground
and the dates right we need the team one
team two and the winner final right so
for that I will write DF uncore
teams
underscore uh let's say
2019 to DF uncore teams dot
drop
date
comma
margin
ground ground okay and I will give
access to
one then DF uncore
teams this is nothing just a data frame
name Dore teore
head so as you can see we have removed
the uh margin and the dat
and the ground
right so uh let me display the whole
rows DF uncore teams _
201199 right so we have now three
columns 725 rows before we have six
colum right 725 R okay so now what we
will do here we will do have feature
selection okay so I will write DF teams
201019 to data frame
DF _
teams
201019 do
reset
index drop equals to
true and here what I did I did the reset
the index of uh this data frame this
data
frame while dropping the old Index right
and now what I will do I will set a
value of one in the winning team column
for the rows where the winner column is
the name
as okay name as the uh Team one column
and the same I will do for the team two
also later on so I will write here DF
uncore teams uncore
2019 DOT
log TF TF
teams
2019 dot
winner equals to
DF _ teams _
Dot
teamore
one and uh like
winning
team equal to
one right and okay it's
DF and I will copy
this paste it
down and now I am set I will set the
value of two in the winning team column
for the rows where the winner column is
same as the team two
okay here I write team
two team
two
right so now I will drop the winning
team column from the data frame DF
underscore
teams
201019 to
DF
teams drop
winning
team XIs = to
one right so now I will display the
first few rows of the modified data
frame using uh this DF teams doad DF
uncore teams
201019 do head right let's run it
okay what is saying uh DF _ teams drop
winning team what's the issue winning
team not found in
Access okay W is capital I
guess
no now as you can see we have dropped
the winning team right let me run it
once again right so moving forward we
will uh split the data set now theing
data set and the testing data set okay
now we will import here the train test
plate from the escalan model
selection and so for that I will write
from SK scalan do model underscore
selection
import
train test split train test split is
nothing it will uh you know split your
data side into some portion to training
some portion to testing as per
your
numbers
right okay so
here I will
write so here we will create some dummy
variables for the team name so I will
write
final equals to PD do
get
uh
dummies
DF
teams
comma
prefix =
to
D go
one
comma T go
to and then comma
columns equals
to teams okay team underscore
one
comma
team
teamore
to right so here x equals to the final
dot drop
winner okay then comma AIS to one so
what I did here uh I'm extracting the
features by dropping the winner column
okay so here yal
to
final
winner and here what I'm doing assigning
the winner column as the target
variable right and here what I will do I
will split the data into training and
the testing sets using a test size of 20
and a random set of 42 right I will tell
you
xcore
train comma
xcore test
Yore train
y test =
to
tr test
split X comma
y comma test
size equals to
0.20 and the
random State equals to
4 so here test size 0.20 means the
testing will be for the 20% and the
training will be of the 80% of the data
set right it will split into 80 and 20
okay automatically let me run it okay
pd. Dum
is some columns name is
wrong okay one more error
this winner key
winner fin to
winner okay some type of
mistake will be
cap okay again X is not
defined X is not defined now defined so
here let me see final.
head
yeah five rows and 50 columns like team
one Afghanistan it's a particular from
the particular team
right okay uh
so moving forward let's apply random
Forest classifier algorithm okay will I
will first do like this yeah so first I
will apply the import the random Forest
module from escan so for that I will
from SK
Lear do
Ensemble
import
random
Forest
classifier okay then create uh let's
create a random forest classifier with
the linear kernel so for that I will
write RF random Forest equals to
random
Forest See
Fire n
underscore
estimators equals to 100 comma
Max T = to
20 comma
random state
to
Z
okay so let's fit the classifier on the
training data so for that I will write
rf.
fit xcore
train train comma y let's go
train and let's make the prediction on
the test data set for that I will write
prediction equal to RF do
predict X
test and let's calculate the training
set score score = to RF
doore then xcore train comma Yore
train
right so uh let's calculate the test
score as well so I will write here score
RF
score test comma Yore
test and let's print the training set
accuracy with three decimal places
okay how you can do let me training
set accuracy
comma this is how you can set the
decimal points percentage dot
3F
right
percent
scope okay uh let's set the test set
accuracy
print test
set
accuracy accuracy
percent same
point3
F percentage for this
scod
right okay let me run
it so as you can see the training set
accuracy is 75% and the test set
accuracies
almost 60% right so now evaluate let's
evaluate the best model on the test set
test data right for that I will write
here
ranking equals to PD dot we have two
more uh files like which is ICC ranking
and the fixtures file right read
dot fixures mean means uh 2023 fixtures
who will play with whom and
when read
CSV
ICC ranking dots
CSV this will read the ICC ranking from
the ICC ranking. CSC file and the
fixures
file bd.
read CSV
pictures.
CSV right and here I will write
prediction underscore
set so let's analyze an empty list to
store prediction results
okay okay PD do CSV not
CSV uh mod Panda has
no oh my bad
sorry
yeah so now let's go to insert team
rankings into the fixures data frame
based on team one and the team two
columns right so I will write here
fixtures do
insert one
comma
the
first position
right
fixures team
one dot
map then the
ranking
ranking.
set and
index for the team
name
okay so let's run it
and so as you can see here the round
number the first position second
position team one team two and this is
the location gr results like this okay
so let's fill the missing values in the
first position and the second position
columns in their respective means so for
that I will write here with the mean
value we'll uh fill the missing values
fixtures
first
position
fixtures
first
position dot fill
n
pictures first
position dot
mean
so I will copy the same for the second
position and paste it here right I will
write
here second
position and here
also second
position second position do mean right
fixtures let's see the
data okay some
uh first
position okay spelling mistake is
there if you want to become an AI expert
and gain handsome salary packages look
at wide range of a IML courses by simply
learn in collaboration with top
universities across Ross the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
program you will gain expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT explainable AI
machine learning algorithm supervised
and unsupervised learning model training
and optimization and there is much more
on the list with handson experience in
tools like chat jpt d python open CV and
tens oflow you will catch the eye of top
recruiter so what are you waiting for so
hurry up and roll now a year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
these courses find the course Link in
the description box below
yeah so now you can see the NN values
gone uh with the mean value it came
right okay but not came in the second
position
right okay for
that
okay here spelling mistake is
there yeah so as you can see the second
position andn values Al also
gone okay
so now let's uh predict the winning team
based on the position in the fixtures
okay
so so this is the code uh so here what
we are doing uh we are just uh writing
the first position uh second position
team one team two as well the rows wise
and here we are
creating a data frame for the prediction
set and here we are creating a backup of
the prediction uh set data frame and the
last one is for the displaying the first
few rows of the prediction
data
right okay so this is come and let's
transform the data set using like one
hot encoding for the team one and the
team two columns
right for that I will write so what we
are doing here we are transferring the
data set using uh one hot encoding for
the team one and the team two right here
for the team one and team two here we
are finding the missing columns in the
final data set compared to the transform
uh this uh prediction data set okay what
we have created here right and the
setting the missing columns in the
prediction uh set data frame to zero and
the then keep Only The Columns and the
last one is here what we are doing we
are dropping the winner column for the
prediction set right let me run it so
yes 0 0 0 0 okay
right so now so let's interpret the
model results so for that I will write
so here what I will do will make the
prediction using RF okay random Forest
on the prediction set and printing the
winner for each fixture based on the uh
prediction set okay so here I will write
predictions equals to RF do
predict prediction
set
right for I in
range of fixtures
dot
shape
zero then
print backup
prediction underscore
set dot
iog I comma
one then
plus I will write here what this it will
look good and the backup One
Plus
backup underscore prediction underscore
set do
iog I comma
right
if
predictions
I equ = to
1 then what will happen Okay let me give
some spaces for the better
visual okay then print the
winner
Okay Plus backup of
prediction set do
iog I comma
1 or else
else
Sprint the
finner
V of
Plus backup prediction
set set.
then I
comma
0 okay 01 will predict
then for this space I will write
print it will give the on line space
okay so okay let me run
it so as you can see the New Zealand
okay let me give space between New
Zealand versus England so I will write
here
space yeah so here you can see the New
Zealand England so England born here
Pakistan born it's like this okay so as
sorry so as per the data top four teams
are
coming as per the data the teams
qualify uh okay I like qualified
teams for the
semi finals as
per the
data on
vs
okay so here I will write
Sami
to First this
Pakistan
comma
Australia
England wait
comma India so these are the four teams
which are qualified for the same is as
for the winning have wins see India wi
wi Pakistan right so again I'm saying
this is for
uh this uh semis are coming from the
data okay in present anything can happen
so now I will
final uh do who will win the semi-finals
and uh let's see the who which team
qualified for the finals right so here
what I did is I in initialized an empty
list to store the position of the teams
in the ranking later on uh I did the
loop through the list of matches and add
the rankings of the team to the position
list with this and moving here you will
see the initialize and empty list to
store the match predictions okay and
here I have initialized with the zero
right for the IJ for the zero for the
iteration here the
loop I will it will Loop through the
positions list to create match
prediction and later on here it will
compare the position of the two teams in
the match
right and moving down
uh it will this one it will uh you know
convert the prediction set list into the
Panda's data frame here the backup will
create uh make okay for the prediction
uh set right and here uh what I'm doing
I'm identifying the missing columns in
prediction set compared to the final
data frame right and
here I am adding the missing columns to
the prediction set data frame and set
their values to zero right okay uh
here this one it is for the reorder uh
of the prediction set columns to match
the final data frames order right and
later on here for it will again the loop
through the prediction set data frame
and print the match prediction and the
winner the last
is what it will do it will call the
clean and predict function with the
provided arguments right so if you will
run it the the the first match is
Pakistan versus Australia Australia won
England versus India India won so the
finals between the teams qualified for
the finals
are
okay finals teams
are ICC for
C final
teams as per the data
are okay so I will WR have finals equals
to
Australia
right
India
okay so
here so here what I do clean the data
apply ranking and use the classifier to
predict the final outcome right so I
will write the clean and the predict
data function and
predict
finals comma ranking comma final comma
okay RF RF is for the uh random Forest
classifier
right so what it will do it will clean
the the data then apply the ranking see
clean the data apply the ranking okay
and use the classifier to predict the
final outcomes so let's see who is
winning so Australia versus India India
is winning the final World Cup okay so
this is based on the data what we have
collected from the kagle or the other
sources right so anything can happen in
the present right it's
Cricket right and the you can download
these CSV files from the description box
below and if you
want uh the full code you can comment
down uh in the comment section uh you
want the full code right this full code
and thank you for watching this video
till then stay safe and keep learning
with simply learn thank
you staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here